in der ferne ragt der rote felsen aus
der nordsee
das meer zeigt sich an diesem morgen von
seiner ruhigen seite und der wind vom
vortag hat nachgelassen
der arbeitstag von sven kühn beginnt
früh noch vor sonnenaufgang holt er
seine reusen einfängt taschen krebse und
sven köhn ist fischer in der fünften
generation einer der letzten
vorhergesagt
ja der hat schon gute zwei kilo
das frühe aufstehen die harte arbeit die
wenige freie zeit kein einfacher job
oftmals seien keine lust mehr man
verdient daran nichts da also ende der
saison macht man ja einen strich und
sagt wie ist die saison gelaufen und
dann auch scheiße eigentlich nur mal
eben so wie triebs kosten reinbekommen
und da fragt man sich tatsächlich macht
macht man das weiter und dann frühjahr
sagt man acht kommt neun mal konnten wir
diese saison will und dann fährt man
raus dann hat man ein super
sonnenaufgang
dann sagt man ja eigentlich das
entschuldigt das ganze gehirn
[Musik]
ein roter fels im meer rund zwei
kilometer lang und 800 meter breit
das ist helgoland auf der hauptinsel
liegt das kleinste naturschutzgebiet
deutschlands hier jagen sie mit
fotoapparat und feldstecher jetzt gehst
du unten
die dritte runde und dann etwas rein
turmfalke die lange anna haben sie hier
nicht im visier
das ist ein stück darüber über den
kormoran siehst du ihn direkt an der
langen anna so ein bisschen noch ja ja
ja matthias wenn und thomas haben meine
ron diva mit teufeln knöpfe und
trottenberg mal geben wir dem finger
nach fliegt direkt unter der könnte
jetzt müssten bloßem auge sehen
alljährlich findet die beflügeln der
rallye statt wer die meisten vogelarten
sieht gewinnt man kann so ein tag auf
irland im herbst und warum laufen kann
irgendwie nichts sehen wirklich nur 34
vögel also das wird ja die insel er ist
das kann am nächsten tag komplett
rappelvoll sein da sind park 1004
hielten den begriff da sind alle busse
voll und das ist eben nicht übertrieben
sondern ist so dass man in einem busch
vielleicht dann 20 vögel aber davon auch
wo acht unterschiedliche arten und all
so was nicht das findet man sonst in
deutschland eben normalerweise nicht die
insel ein paradies für schräge vögel auf
der suche nach seltenen
das summer goldhähnchen die waldschnepfe
habt ihr einen vogel ist hier nicht
beleidigend gemeint haben wir alle das
klar ich komme jetzt über 20 30 jahre
dafür eigentlich 50 jahre alt ich bin 50
jahre alt jemand 100 zwölfter besucher
figur land ja das ist schon heftig man
fühlt sich wie zuhause
dass man kommt ja wahnsinnig runter also
das ist so eine sache man geht morgens
raus ist den ganzen tag draußen und
kommt total runter man ist einfach in
einer anderen welt
man kann man diesen ganzen kram ist
vergessen die auch frischer luft ist
herrlich die lange anna das wahrzeichen
der insel
die bunten hunger booten am hafen
helgoland skyline deutschlands einzige
hochseeinsel hat viel zu bieten treibt
es bunt hier treffen vogel enthusiasten
auf robben fans schnäppchenjäger auf
naturliebhaber grün ist das land rote
kennt und weiß der sand das sind die
farben von helgoland nicht unbedingt der
originellste spruch aber zutreffend auf
jeden fall
während die vögel in die ferne schweifen
sind hierzulande viele reif für die
insel helgoland ist ausgebucht aber
jeder tourist in diesen zeiten eine
gefahr die anzahl der menschen die
kommen dürfen daher begrenzt die
überfahrt war ja alles wurde eingeteilt
tische zugewiesen aber sehr freundlich
das personal und eigentlich so wie man
es auch kennt nur etwas gesitteter
alleine mit schnitten pulli durch die
gegend laufen ist natürlich dänemark ist
schon schwierig teilweise und alle
anderen gebiete in europa sind eben auch
teilweise risikogebiete und dann bleibt
man halt in deutschland und helfen land
ist war für uns so das nächste
maske tragen hat man sich daran gewöhnt
ich bin tatsächlich hier fast noch ein
bisschen vorsichtiger als zu hause weil
die eben hier auf ihrer insel glaube ich
echt ein problem kriegen wenn dir das
hier eingeschleppt kriegen von uns
touristen deswegen halte ich mich noch
extremer daran als zu hause was ich zu
hause eigentlich auch nur schmöker
schnaps schokolade die schnäppchenjäger
sind los der zollfreie einkauf lockt die
menschen schon seit jahrzehnten auf die
und helgoland wäre nicht helgoland
genosse man hier nicht deinen guten
schluck whisky
dann geht es gleich los ich drücke euch
mal die gläser schon mal in die hand
bitte noch nicht trinken wir trägt man
schön zusammen erst mal ein bisschen es
super wenn ihr wollt
einmal in der woche lädt man bei haiders
zum whisky tasting auf der terrasse
seines duty free shops im oberland
wissen wie heißt übersetzt wasser des
lebens das heißt es übersetzt genau das
gleiche wie aquavit und wodka auch
tatsächlich kommt bloß aus verschiedenen
regionen der erde aus den über 100
whisky sorten werden sechs edle tropfen
verköstigt sascha s pass hat es vor 20
jahren aus bitterfeld hierher
verschlagen
vom image des puzzle felsens ist
helgoland längst weit entfernt erzählt
er
viele sind auf das wertige sachen aus
man merkt richtig dass die leute
genießen wollen und nicht wer diese
masse abläuft so wie früher wird das
nicht hat man zehn euro linie bacardi
mitgenommen und das war's heutzutage
sucht man schon hier also die
spezielleren sachen die butterfahrten
längst passé neben den tagesgästen gibt
es viele stammgäste die einen ganz
anderen spirit schätzen seit meiner
kindheit bin ich schon bereits hier und
wir sind im jeden jahr hier die kinder
geboren sind natürlich noch mehr
und das schöne ist dass man hier so
abgeschieden ist es ist einfach ein
eiland zum erholen
viele denken ist ein langweilig und ich
würde sagen ist das ausgesprochen
spannend und durch den ja durch durch
diese atmosphäre oder auch durch diesen
wind kriegt man auch den kopf frei
also man kann sich im grunde einstellen
auf das was man sieht und riecht und
alles andere ist plötzlich unglaublich
weit weg
ankommen geht nur per se oder per luft
henning martens hat seine kindheit auf
helgoland verbracht seit sieben jahren
bringt der einheimische und touristen
nach und von den täglich zweimal
helgoland hin und zurück das sagen wir
ganz viele die das eben nur ab und zu
mal erleben uns antworten das ist ja
toll aus sie habe den besten job der
welt aber es wird zur routine dass sie
immer alles einfach so
das ist halt jeden tag champagner wird
auch immer langweilig
60 km wasserweg liegen zwischen insel
und festland genug um zoll- und
mehrwertsteuer zu entfliehen
corona entkommt man nicht kaum
passagiere sorge um den arbeitsplatz
kurzarbeit langweilig war es zuletzt
nicht
aber es hat er auch was gutes meine
lebensgefährtin lebt ja auf der insel
und da war ich ostern und hab ich den
garten gemacht und da kam die singvögel
an und haben sich einmal auf die beine
gesetzt und auf die die hatten gar keine
angst mehr weil die auf völlig perplex
war um hier keine menschenmassen
rumlaufen also auch jörg singer ist
wieder am ort seiner kindheit gelandet
ursprünglich stammt er aus konstanz am
bodensee wuchs ein paar jahre auf
helgoland auf verließ die insel um als
unternehmer karriere zu machen
dann wagte er sich mit seiner familie
zurück nach erholt unser weile ist er
bürgermeister seit einem jahrzehnt auf
diesem sehr besonderen fleckchen erde
die lage der insel so weit in der
nordsee draußen die nähe die
ungezwungenheit wo man schnell hin
laufen kann man kann sich schnell
verabreden wenn man sport machen will
beispielsweise oder man ist unheimlich
schnell in der natur also dass es eine
hohe entschleunigung möglichkeit gibt
hat wenn es mal stressig ist und dann
einfach die luft dieses einzigartigen
also wenn der der westwind über das fett
weg schmecken die luft raus geht jeden
anderen ort auf der welt und das ist
schon was besonderes eine besondere lage
die zu corinna zeiten aber auch nicht
hilft drei monate war helgoland
abgeregelt insel arrest nannten sie es
eine schwierige situation aber keine
aussichtslose
wir haben das fraunhofer institut hier
deutsches zentrum für maritime
technologien und wir haben den offshore
bereich der natürlich wenn der wind weht
geld verdient arbeitsplätze sichert und
auch damit zur kritischen infrastruktur
gehört was natürlich alle stabilisierend
wird also wir nur vom tourismus leben
würden dann wird es uns deutlich
schlechter gehen
doch für die rund 1500 insulaner ist und
bleibt der tourismus existenziell
wichtig keine gäste keine einnahmen
der lock down hat die menschen hart
getroffen sven kühn trifft so
spätschicht am hafen von der fischerei
allein kann der 47-jährige nicht leben
und so übernimmt der in der saison
gleich drei jobs parallel er fischt er
vermietet ferienwohnungen und er steuert
die kleine dünen fähre die die
hauptinsel und nachbarinsel verbindet
das gute am insel leben ist sagt er
man kennt sich man hilft sich auf herr
müller
wenn man die auf helgoland ist ja fühlt
man sich ja auch als wir den lockdown
hatten
man war quasi abgeschottet vom festland
man hätte eigentlich normal
normalerweise hier so weiter leben
können weil ich kann ja eigentlich
keiner zu ende und es kommt auch keine
runter von der insel und das war schon
sehr positiv dass man auch zusammen
gehalten hat und das war schon echt toll
router fels und weiße düne ein
leuchtturm ein zeltplatz zwei
restaurants aber vor allem viel natur
und rund 130.000 quadratmeter feinster
sandstrand
das ist helgolands zweit insel die
vorgelagerte dünn
hier geht es weit beschaulicher zu
michael jansen kommt eigentlich aus
glems haben seit zehn jahren ist er der
dünen chef sein job er sorgt dafür dass
auf seiner insel alle gut miteinander
auskommen
kommen sie noch mal ein stück zurück die
tiere sind heute morgen ins wasser
geschickt worden
ich versuche die ganze zeit wieder raus
zu kommen muss man die hier so eine
barriere bilden und auch so dicht dann
überlegen sie sich das war jetzt gerade
so ein kleiner versuch aber so richtig
geheuer ist noch nicht da stand sie auch
noch ein paar meter weiter vor und dann
das waren beides kegelrobben die bühne
teilen sich die gäste mit seehunden und
auch hier gilt abstand halten 30 meter
mindestens allerdings nicht wegen
korrupter mit 2 30 und 300 kilo bis zu
20 km h schneller am strand man soll das
also nicht unterschätzen natürlich nur
auf eine kurze distanz im wasser
schaffen sie bis zu 40
und ich sage mal wenn die flieger bei
der größe aufrecht stehen würden würden
sich einige überlegen ob sie sich daran
gehen würden massige meeressäuger
hautnah
das gibt es noch
nach helgoland wollte michael jansen
übrigens auch gar keinen fall
weil sie die marine vor jahren auf die
insel mitten in der nordsee versetzen
wollte doch dem damaligen sanitäter wie
keine war ein glücksfall sagt der hund
erst mal nicht sogar von begeistert aber
just in dem moment eigentlich als ich
die insel betreten hatte war es einfach
die große liebe und die hält einfach an
bis heute diese lage hier mitten in der
nordsee
die menschen sind ja auch besonders hier
so ein bisschen leben und leben lassen
wenn du hier keine silberlöffel klaus
dann kannst du eigentlich kann ich tun
und lassen was du willst
die große liebe helmut es ist wie ebbe
und flut sagen sie hier
alle seien kommen und nur helgoland ist
der fels in der brandung
[Musik]